e
thank you there we go I'm going to start
over um now we are broadcasting on on
YouTube so this is the subcommittee uh
hearing
for House Bill
225 uh the the title of the bill is
relative to prohibiting the use of
currency that could be detrimental to
privacy rights this bill was introduced
last year by representative beler and it
was held over uh the summer and and then
this year sent to interim study and this
is the interim study work session on the
bill uh the committee felt the bill was
not ready for prime time and the sponsor
agreed with us and sent
us some uh written testim
he says this is representative Mike
Belcher regarding the necessity of for
such a bill as this I believe it become
more and more clear that it is in fact
wholly necessary to make measures to
protect New Hampshire residents from the
burgeoning digital control mechanisms
that threaten freedom and liberty
however many legitimate issues have been
raised regarding the exact wording of
this bill I would request that the
committee consider taking whatever
action deemed most appropriate to
promote the study of the issue for the
development of better language such that
another better Bill might be might come
forward in the next session so those are
his
comments and so we're going to do
something a little bit different uh we
have uh we have Nick Anthony who is uh
an expert on digital currency from the
KO Institute and he's joining us by zoom
and we thank him for his time we got
started a little late here so Nick I'm
going to turn it over to you you have
written
testimony which was emailed to the
committee last night um representative
Gibbs I have a copy for you
oh I I saw your email but okay there's a
written copy thank you representative
copy thank you Mr chairman I will take
one actually if you have it I don't know
if I saw that
email see we'll pass that on and then uh
Mr Anthony I'm going to turn it over to
you and I'm gonna have to move my
microphone to the speaker so that the
people on YouTube that that will listen
to this can hear you speak oh I
apologize I do have it actually that was
attached to the same email I do have it
I and I did read it okay great all right
so without further Ado uh Mr Anthony
we'll give you up to 10 minutes and then
we might want to ask you some questions
good and I'm gonna turn
off go
ahead well Vice chair Amon and members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
Nicholas Anthony and I'm a policy
Analyst at the KO Institute Center for
monetary and financial Alternatives a
fellow at the human rights foundation
and the author of the book digital
currency or digital control decoding
cbdc and the future of money the term
Central Bank digital currency or cbdc
has quickly shifted from an academic
idea to an economic reality according to
the human rights Foundation cbdc tracker
over 1.5 billion ion people currently
live in countries where cbdcs have been
rolled out yet many people still have no
idea what a cbdc is let alone whether
their government is pursuing one it's
for this reason that I'm grateful for
the opportunity to testify here today so
first what is a cbdc in short it's a
digital National currency that is a
direct liability of a country Central
Bank typically discussions of cbdcs
revolve around the retail model where
cbdc is designed for consumers to use in
day-to-day purchases at first glance
this description might sound
uncontroversial considering most of us
make some form of digital payment every
day what is different with a cbdc
however is that it's it's the government
would ultimately be the one processing
those
transactions so rather than have
transactions spread across banks credit
unions and the like Financial
transactions would be centralized in the
hands of the federal government and it's
for this reason the creation of a US
cbdc would pose a fundamental threat to
financial privacy likely the greatest
since the enactment of the bank secrecy
Act and the establishment of the third
party Doctrine with so much information
in hand a cbdc would enable the
government to restrict Financial Freedom
in countless
ways unfortunately the observations in
practice have given us little to be
hopeful about if I were to summarize the
international experience thus far it
would boil down to two
categories a restriction on the lives of
citizens and a waste of taxpayer
resources for example in Nigeria the
government caused a cash shortage in
hopes of spurring adoption when only
0.5% of the population was using its
cbdc in the Bahamas the government will
soon Force Banks to distribute its cbdc
and most recently in Thailand the
government launched a quasi cbdc through
a digital wallet that restricts payments
to government approved Goods at
government approved stores within the
district listed on each person's ID
card these restrictions are also taking
place in subtler ways as documented in
the human rights Foundation cbdc tracker
officials in the Bahamas the Eastern
Caribbean currency Union Jamaica Lebanon
Nigeria Peru Rwanda the Solomon Islands
and more have all said the goal is to go
cashless and that cbdcs are the way they
will get
there but what about the question of
whether cbdcs are an appropriate use of
taxpayer
resources again from the international
experience we see that governments that
have launched cbdcs are struggling to
get anyone to use them on a day-to-day
basis the public generally recognizes
that their needs are being met by
existing options like Mobile Banking pay
payment apps and
cash so in the best case it's a waste of
taxpayer resources because it does not
offer any unique benefits that are not
already being provided for by the market
in the worst case cbdcs could threaten
Financial privacy freedom and markets at
large issues that have already begun to
surface with these concerns in mind what
role is there though at the state
level it's a difficult question members
of Congress have the authority to limit
the Federal Reserve so it doesn't move
forward but options are limited at the
state level there are really three
legislative approaches that officials
have taken or considered thus far the
first option is to prohibit the use of
cbdcs
entirely given concerns on the table
it's understandable why this option
might appear
appealing however it poses significant
concerns a imagine if a constituent went
to the Bahamas on vacation and came home
with some of the Bohemian cbdc left over
how would enforcement work would the
state establish a surveillance Network
to monitor travel would the citizen be
searched Upon returning to the state
unfortunately this path can quickly
devolve into its own assault on
financial privacy and
Freedom the second option lies in what
many states have done over the past few
years namely classify CBD s within State
Statute so they are excluded from the
definition of money in the Uniform
Commercial Code or
UCC unfortunately these options also
have extended
consequences a person or business may
still use a cbdc under this approach
it's just that they are not afforded the
legal protections one might typically
expect Under the UCC so again it's
unfortunately the citizens that stand to
lose a third option is to explicitly
prohibits State agencies from using a
cbdc or participating in cbdc programs
we the first option is too hot and the
second option is perhaps too cold this
third option might be just right it does
not restrict the freedoms of individual
citizens but it does limit the hands of
government now unfortunately all three
options appear vulnerable to the
supremacy clause in fact Florida
Governor Ronda santis acknowledge that
his bill would likely be overridden if
Congress chose to move forward but it
should be said that the 10th Amendment
Center has argued that the supremacy
clause is not so black and white in
practice the same argument came up when
States initially began to legalize
cannabis and the experience with the
ongoing delay of real ID implementation
shows that states are if nothing else
able to establish roadblocks that slow
down the process
with that in mind there's a fourth
option on the table that should also be
considered all three legislative
approaches have in common that they send
a message they show that states are
watching and they will not silently fall
into line however there are other ways
to do this too State officials are in a
unique position to bridge the gap
between citizens and the larger
government raising awareness and making
sure concerns are being heard by members
of Congress is crucial that can be done
through town halls op-eds letters and
even meetings such as this one these
Avenues should not be
underestimated in closing the committee
is correct to keep an eye on the rise of
cbdcs and what options are on the table
I I thank CH uh Vice chair Amon and
members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak on this issue and I
welcome any questions you may have large
thank you very much uh for your
questions thank you Mr chairman thanks
Nick for your testimony I appreciate it
um so if I understand you correctly the
KO
Institute recommendation would be
passing similar legislation to some of
the other states or recommending that
New Hampshire consider
legislation that limit limits New
[Music]
Hampshire's participation or ability to
accept digital
currency as a more means of
tender uh essentially
to message the federal
government that we do not approve of
not Nick were you able to hear
question uh look like it okay see what's
going on here by the stunned silence uh
there you are maybe not I I had we had a
little feedback earlier I turned the
microphone off okay so we were talking
to you Nick and you able to hear us so
I'll I'll let representative MCU repeat
the question hi hi it's representative
Tim MCU um so I'm
just gonna sort of paraphrase then is it
the KO institute's suggestion that we
can that New Hampshire consider
legislation that would perhaps limit the
states of New Hampshire's ability to
accept digital currency as a means of
payment for any sort of of payment to
the state as a means to essentially send
a message to the United States federal
government that we don't approve of uh
this this sort of invasive
privacy
uh type of currency like like like the
way you've described it being
implemented in other
countries so I have to be very careful
uh in that the KO Institute can't
endorse any legislation
but what I can say is that if states are
to take a legislative approach I think
that's the best option on the table is
to make sure that it's saying that the
state agencies are not going to require
this as payment or Force citizens to use
it and they're not going to participate
in these programs that make sure that
you're not having any sweeping
restrictions on the citizens and also
you're still managing to send that
message and ultimately have the federal
government have to say something if they
want to push forward with this then they
have to acknowledge why all these states
had a problem with it and why they're
anyway well thank you yes I guess I
follow up um but the but your your
position is pretty clear that it's a
it's an invasive means of tracking
expenditures tracking individual
movements
expenses U all sorts of things that the
the federal government could use for
countless other
things I mean every bit of somebody's
personal
life and and that's
the potentially orwellian future if the
Central Bank digital currency comes to
pass and that's potentially why
North Carolina and several other states
have decided that this isn't the right
way to right way for their state to go I
mean am I am I understanding that
correctly I mean what I what I've read
and and heard from your testimony and
others and and the research from other
states it's it's why it's really not the
New Hampshire way and it's not in line
with our constitutionally protected
right to privacy right in New Hampshire
yeah you you are correct that is why so
many people are concerned about this and
why so many people have been speaking
out just really year after year and it's
why I spend a lot of my time working
here in DC with Congress to try to put
serious restrictions on the Federal
Reserve and the department of the
treasury to say they cannot go ahead and
do this of their own accord because it
represents a
fundamental uh a front to really the
Constitution at large very specifically
the the Fourth Amendment quite obviously
but really it gets into a whole Hornet's
Nest of problems and again to your point
that is why so many states are looking
at this and saying wait no this is not
something that we want to
have you question I I do so we so we
passed set of Bill 255 it was a privacy
act I was one of the sponsors it was one
of the first bills to get signed this
year I mean isn't this kind of a
followup I mean isn't this one of the
things that that we couldn't we didn't
pass it this by any of them but
shouldn't it be one of our legislative
priorities to to look at other things
that we can do to proactively protect
the privacy of our citizens I mean isn't
that what we're seeing happen across the
country yes I I really could not agree
more that this is something that should
be a focus and the timing is really
quite brilliant because across the
country American are noticing that this
financial privacy that they thought they
had and even this General sense of
privacy that they thought they had is
really an illusion of privacy it's been
something that's been chipped away at
for decades and now people are noticing
more than ever before and so it really
is good to get ahead of this and not
wait for the next catastrophe whether
that be a cbdc a a data leak or what
have you it's it's better to get ahead
of these problems and try to fix them
before they become problems that are
affecting people's day-to-day lives yeah
I mean it fright just editorializing it
frightens me now we we you talk about
something in your in your living room
and you know she is listening right the
you know Alexa Siri one of them is
listening and then the next thing you
know you're in your car and you get an
ad for whatever you just talking about I
mean that's creepy
enough yeah represent have a question
do thank you and thank you Mr Anthony um
for coming in in a somewhat unusual
manner um but I appreciate it um I have
a couple of questions one very specific
and the other very general uh the first
specific one is you mentioned that some
countries are have actually decided to
use a uh Central Bank digital
currency uh and what I am wondering
is while such a decision may have been
made is anybody in that in that country
for instance in the Bahamas uh actually
using such a currency and more
specifically if I were to go to the
Bahamas and go to a bank to exchange my
dollars for the local currency would I
get the local currency as I normally
would in a foreign country or would I
get some kind of a digital
currency thank you those are such good
questions
uh on the first one uh unfortunately uh
despite the countless amount of money
that's being spent on these projects
they are not going to good use people
are not using the Central Bank digital
currencies where they've been launched
so one example is in
Nigeria this is the largest population
in Africa if I'm not mistaken only
[Music]
0.5% of the population started using the
cbdc we're seeing that same experience
elsewhere in the Bahamas very few people
are using it and that's why the
government is going to soon Force the
banks to distribute it to try to make
people use it even in China we've seen
examples of people saying they get for
uh follow-up question uh on the specific
on a specific issue
um if I went to the
and got that digital wallet that you
were
describing um and I then went to a
souvenir shop to buy a souvenir could I
actually pay for it with that digital
it of a tricky answer it's a coin flip
so to speak uh one of the big problems
that they've been having in the Bahamas
specifically is to get any Merchant to
on board with this nobody wants to have
a brand new payments terminal on their
desk so they refuse to use it and so you
might find some shops that use it but
the vast majority do not use it and this
cbdc has been out there for I I believe
four years now and it's still just such
a tossup if you have any opportunity to
use
it um oh sorry uh second follow-up
question
um so doesn't that seem to get rid of
the problem that somebody could come
back from the Bahamas and have some of
these uh cbdcs left over because if
they're not using it you're not going to
get it and you're not going to have any
left over it seemed that problem would
exist of a a silver a silver lining when
we consider any of the risks whether in
this case coming back to the states or
with the the financial privacy freedom
and Market concerns that are there is
that if nobody uses them then there
really isn't those problems coming into
practice they they luckily were remain
in the theoretical
realm um I'm not surprised do you have
another question I do may I ask it yeah
we have uh we're 20 minutes in so we
want to keep conscious of time um okay
I'll try and be as quick as I can than
you
uh okay the general question has to do
with the fact that um my bank knows a
great deal about me you mentioned that
this would be the government processing
transactions instead of banks my bank
knows a great deal about me but I don't
trust them with any information that I
don't have to because historically banks
are not that reliable um so I don't give
them any information I don't have to now
I have had to give them a lot of
information but I try and keep it to the
minimum uh the federal government on the
other hand already knows everything
about me because I used to work for the
federal government and I had to get what
was very like a security clearance it in
fact used the same form as a security
clearance I got investigated the federal
government knows everything about me um
and that was part of my job um
and the bottom line for me was that I
trusted the federal government more than
I trusted the bank uh based on the
historical record so I guess my general
question for you is why do you trust the
bank more than you trust the federal
government oh gosh there's a lot of
angles that I could go with this with
but the main what I want to focus
because our time's limited is I much
rather have my information at one place
here and they have only what they need
just like you described only what they
need and I have someone else with only
what they need so that if any one of
those is compromised whether it's a hack
whether it's a employee mishap or
something else at least not everything
is
taken when it comes to having everything
in the hands of the federal government
I'm very glad to hear that you have had
a positive experience but I very much
worry that if we talk about having every
American's information in a central
database that's not only going to
present a target for like four profit
hackers that might be targeting the
banks but unfortunately that's also
going to inspire this country's enemies
who are going to do it as an act of
warfare as well and not think about it
in the same economic calculation of is
it worth it to go after this it's just
going to be we're trying to completely
undermine the system and it presents a
unfortunately unprecedented Target in
what it would have and it's a little
rare that that uh somebody like myself
speaking from the the KO Institute a
Libertarian Think Tank will have room
for agreement with officials from the
Federal Reserve but this is even
something that the Federal Reserve has
come out and said we are deeply
concerned about and it's something that
we don't know how to
you Nick um so sou North Carolina just
passed house 690 and they did it they
even overrode the governor's veto with a
bipartisan
override
thank House Bill 690 in uh North
Carolina they overrode the governor's
veto in a bipartisan way Democrats and
Republicans came together to pass this
fairly simple bill it has a definition
of Central Bank digital currency and
then it just says that state agencies
and it has a list uh basically shall not
uh be involved with the testing or using
a central bank dig what why do you think
they did that uh first part of the
question and if you could project from
short term out to long term what is what
do you think is your projection as the
the risk of a central bank digital
currency being imposed on us at some
point in the future maybe during a
financial crisis or some other
event so I think uh specifically on the
the state level I think one benefit to
take out of there is that if we have
States speaking out and saying that they
are not going to be involved in this
project they're not going to require it
force
it basically a a signal a kind of
I will say It's seems to be more of an
if question now a few years ago it felt
like a when most people were talking
about it as an
inevitable but what you flagged is so
important because it used to be that it
was inevitable that'll happen no matter
what good times or bad times now it
feels like an if question for at least
the good times but if there's a crisis
heaven forbid another pandemic a war a
recession or or what have you we have
seen that the federal government will
mobilize quickly and specifically the
Federal Reserve and the department of
the treasury will mobilize quickly both
were considering in cbdc during the
pandemic and it was really only by the
speed of what was happening uh
interrupting plans so it's very likely
that one could be rolled out if a
sufficient crisis were to rise granted
again I just want to emphasize that
becomes harder and harder with the more
people that are speaking out because
those concerns have to be addressed if
it is to
happen all right any any further
questions any further
questions thank you very much for your
time Nick and uh you broke
believe it or not in the 21st century
that's great super so thank you very
much and you're welcome to stick around
or or drop off I know you have a flight
to catch but we we'll continue the
conversation here thank you so much and
if you have any questions please feel
free to reach out to me anytime I'm
always happy to lend it very good all
you all right uh I think
we I I I appreciated having someone
who's been thinking about this for years
great you want to try your own
off uh okay I think uh the master switch
there never mind
this just leave it so we can everybody
can
talk there you go yeah okay uh I I
appreciated the remote testimony uh we
might have had a few hiccups for the
YouTube stream but we'll get it worked
out next time um any any thoughts on uh
how to proceed with our subcommittee
recommendation I think it's just
representative M and myself yeah so
thank you Mr chairman I think it's um so
if I understand correctly
our only motion to make is to recommend
further legislation I mean when we exec
the bill I mean we will have an
executive session and we'll recommend as
a full
committee yeah we we'll recommend as a
full committee that someone should file
another
LSR or or not yeah and that really is a
bit
non-binding it is very
non-binding I would say that that the
current bill 225 is not recommended for
future legislation and mainly because
the definitions aren't very well defined
right um and then maybe somewhere in the
blurb we mentioned that uh I mean this
bill would be a lot closer to something
that I think might get pasted the the
North Carolina the North Carolina and
that's just the latest version so maybe
maybe something else will come out
between now and filing day but re
recommend 225 not for future legislation
with the caveat yeah put it in the blur
in the blur we can recommend just
pointing to this other bill that exists
and that's it's at least a better
defined bill yeah subject matter- wise I
mean it's important we consider for the
reasons I mentioned um I mean it's a
it's a pretty high priority that we do
what we do in New Hampshire which is get
ahead of the game on these types of
issues I mean it's it's important that
we do that that clearly wasn't the right
vehicle it's not the right language
there's some other better language out
there but this committee does it very
well when it comes to considering those
types of issues ahead of parts of the
rest of the country and and we should
continue to do that I think so too
um there's talk in the full committee
about prophylactic legislation haha
prophylactic um but to me you want to
put barriers between incos on our
citizens rights so if there's a
potential incos on a right it's good to
have a barrier there that needs to be
penetrated before the rights are
infringed upon right so that proactive
right it's it's some sure but we want to
do that selectively and carefully so
yeah I agree all right so I'll make a
motion uh not the subcommittee will
recommend not for future recommendation
with the caveat uh just at least making
people aware of uh the South the North
Carolina Bill and and any other simil
bills that have passed recent second
okay all right all in favor I think it's
just me and you Tim oh well there we go
I okay two to nothing anyos no two to
nothing it's amazing what you can
do take five before we start yeah you
want to take five yeah I go to bathroom
five
e
open the subcommittee hearing on House
Bill
1674 so this bill uh I'll just give a
little history on this bill um a former
state senator uh Jim fory asked me to
put this bill in and I worked with him
uh over about a year ago we worked
together to put this bill in uh and you
know we had public hearings on it it was
probably too big of a bite at the Apple
because it contained three different
sections it was make uh have the state
declare gold and silver as legal tender
which several other states have
done um the second one was the state
treasurer would set up a Boolean deposit
depository and at least Texas has done
that already so gold bullion depository
and the third thing which was a little
bit of a stretch was issue digital
tokens as receipts for the bullion those
digital tokens could be redeemable and
exchangeable and there are gold back
digital tokens in the marketplace but
just not backed up by a sovereign state
so nobody's done that yet um and uh in
talk in talking with Senator fora
uh who has since passed away
unfortunately he died in a wind surfing
accident and and has passed but uh in
talking to him his concern is
about uh the fact that uh the you know
the the federal monetary policy seems to
be going off the
rails um and just like some current
stats the you know the the national debt
is 34 plus trillion
uh over 200,000 per
taxpayer the largest budget item in the
federal budget even higher than National
Defense is the interest on the debt it's
over a trillion dollars and our deficit
spending is almost $2 trillion a year so
the government is spending $2 trillion
more than it takes in every year and
that seems to be accelerating and so the
the thought is that um because the go
the federal government has the ability
to print new money they can debase the
currency and that debases the value that
they owe that that 34 trillion plus
dollars they can pay it back in in
dollars that are worth less in the
future and that seems to be the
direction that it's going in how do we
protect our citizens from that uh
process Senator foresight was a big
sound money guy and we know in the state
con or in the Federal Constitution it's
an article 10 it talks about gold and
silver being
money um you know that's a very old so
here here it is I have it on the screen
there any make
anything so that it says the powers
denied to the states they can do the
they cannot do these things and they
they cannot make anything but gold and
silver a tender and payment in debts and
so that's the key phrase that other
states have picked up on
um our committee researcher Kristen has
kindly uh given us a list um this is as
recent as February so this might have
might have changed since
but but there are um I'll list a couple
of the states that have uh some legal
tender laws on the books Arizona Indiana
Kansas City um Kansas sorry Louisiana
Missouri Oklahoma South Carolina
Tennessee Texas Utah and West Virginia
all have some uh some exemption that
take gold and silver and give it the
status of legal
tender one of the things you notice when
you look through this is that a lot of
it has to do with exempting from sales
and income taxes and so our our state
doesn't have a sales or income tax but
we do have business taxes so there might
be some application for businesses to
transact in gold and silver I think the
demand is probably very low at the
current time um so anyway that's a gist
of the original House Bill 16
74 what I did uh at our last session
right before our executive session I
just carved out the legal tender portion
of it so I I Whitted it way back took
out the Boolean depository and took out
the digital
tokens um those are ideas before their
time in my opinion um and just made it
to the legal tender aspect so maybe we
can just limit our discussion to the
legal tender piece of it and that's uh
house
Amendment
2024-25
3H that's the amendment that I'm talking
about if you need a copy I have some
copies
here you want to take a minute to read
it over and this this was sort of mimic
um I think there's some concerns about
uh
municipalities uh accepting gold and
silver and so so the intention would be
to not mandate this but make it uh make
it you know enabling but I don't know
Municipal Association do you want to
have anything to add I know you've
weighed in
up and I'll just when I put this bill in
in November
2023 gold was at $1,900 an ounce and
yesterday it was
2670 20 so it's 40%
more but um the way to think about it is
the value of the dollar has gone down
the purchasing power of that gold stays
roughly the same so that's a really
difficult thing for the American mind to
comprehend because we're not used to
dealing in different currencies uh maybe
the old before the EU was established
you would think about uh you know
exchange rates between countries but um
so anyway that's just a a little piece
of tribute would you like to introduce
yourself sure thank you so much um
representative aan my name is Katherine
hack I represent the 234 cities and
towns in New Hampshire at the municipal
Association and we did have some
conversations and some testimony um
around the original Bill and some
concerns we had about municipalities
being mandated and working with the
sponsors um we discussed having it be
enabling legislation because as a
representative Aman just pointed out it
would be like trading in foreign
currency on a regular basis and
municipalities especially our smallest
communities are not set up to trade um
and any type of currency on a daily
basis and check prices um and these are
tax dollars that we're working with so
if the price went down one day and we
happened to trade because we needed to
make payroll because we were even in
under enabling we could potentially be
losing tax dollars in the trade um of
in the exchange of funds right so we
also if it's physical silver and gold
you know the physical Metals um maybe
Palladium Platinum whatever it happens
to be we don't have facilities to store
them safely and we are required already
by law to bring $1,500 or more to the
bank on a daily basis that's already in
state law so if you can imagine an you
know a small piece of gold that you know
right a gold coin essentially an ounce
we would and the only place to go would
be to conquer to the treasurer so then
we would have be paying employees
mileage and time so for for
municipalities it it it might be a
challenge um under any type of mandated
system for for us to operate safely
effectively and efficiently and of
course preserving the principle of the
tax dollar because there's also costs
for trading and spot and there's all
sorts of other logistics as far as a
digital currency
um that would have to be much more
understood and socialized for
municipalities to understand um what
platform thank you thank you very much
any anything anything you'd like to say
representative
Gibbs okay go
ahead thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for coming in um I guess my question
is is fairly General um
are the cities in town set up to act as
gold exchanges and calculate the price
uh since taxes are are calculated in
dollars calculate the worth of if
somebody brought in gold coins to pay
taxes are they set up to calculate the
worth um and what would they have to do
to be set up that
way so thank you for your question um
that's an excellent question no we are
we are not set up that way and we
are to to purchase silver and gold right
now you'd have to go to a silver and
gold dealer in addition we don't report
um other than payroll taxes to the IRS
and anytime you trade in more than
$10,000 in in Precious Metals you do
have to do reporting to the IRS so those
would be also additional pieces but
essentially someone could come in at
9:00 in the morning and pay something in
silver and gold or ask for their
paycheck in silver and gold depending
whether it's an employer or a taxation
and gold could be trading at
$2,641 and by the end of the day it
could be higher or lower and of
course we're we're decoupled from the US
dollar and we do business based on the
the value of the US dollar not based on
another um commodity so because it's a
commodity right now it's in the
Commodities market so again there would
have to be a lot of Education and
Training for a municipality to take that
on and the preservation
of your tax dollar maintainance value of
course is first and foremost on our
minds uh and a comment as a followup
sure this is this is freefor all you can
okay um I'm uh I I actually am familiar
with using different currencies most
Americans I agree probably aren't but
when I was young I traveled through uh a
lot of small countries one after another
after another over a period of a few
weeks and was constantly
uh working from one currency to another
and what we dealt with were currency
exchanges uh that were set up to
calculate the value of those currencies
one against another or one against the
dollar however that that particular one
worked um so I'm aware of how complex
this kind of thing actually is and
considering that gold is traded as a
commodity which uh well at that time the
uh Yugoslav uh um it may have been the
darar I wouldn't swear to it um whatever
the Yugoslav currency was when
Yugoslavia existed um it it wasn't being
traded as a commodity in the same way
that gold is so I I could see how that
could be a lot more
complicated all right very good thank
you for Testimony um thank you so I'm
GNA make a recommendation for a motion
and a and a report so see if I can get
this out of my so we're going to
recommend that this particular bill is
not recommended for future legislation
but um we may want to consider this
amendment for future legislation or at
least studying it for future legislation
and what I I guess what I would like to
have a better understanding of we just
heard okay let me just finish my thought
here we just heard that municipalities
might not be able to manage it we do
have other states that have done this
and they even have uh sales and income
taxes that they have to deal with so
maybe we need to delve a little more
into how these other states are handling
the concerns that you just raised before
we craft legislation and we would just
narrow it down to the legal tender piece
as like a stepping stone as like a
potential First Step but making sure
that the municipalities aren't burdened
by you know some some unforeseen thing
so recommendation recommendation would
be not for a f future recommendation the
committee report I'm going to mention
studying
existing uh states that have similar and
and then referencing this amendment so
at least people can find the amendment
which is the smaller version of the
original
bill you want to you want to add to that
thank you Mr chairman I I just have a
question and it was actually for the
municipal Association
um well for both of you don't if memory
serves we have a requirement I thought
in statute already maybe our committee
researcher knows um or somebody here
probably already knows don't we have a
requirement that municipalities have to
take cash for for payment of certain
things or was it enabling was that
enabling I thought we passed that at one
point does anybody
remember you do know I don't you don't
know the city of conquer does take cash
I know this because I once had to pay my
property taxes in cash it was a long
story and I won't bore you but the city
of conquer took cash for property tax
yes we are required to take legal tender
okay so the followup the followup Part B
is then um the H how many gold coins and
it's more than one how many gold coins
are legal tender I mean certainly the
American Eagle is legal tender and it's
a gold coin um and it's worth more than
50 bucks which is what's marked on the
so in that case we can take it at its
face value so if it's a $5 coin because
it's our exchange at the bank or or 500
whatever the face value of the coin is
is how we currently have to do business
so for the person handing you that they
would be losing a significant amount of
money MH right because I have a gold
coin in a necklace so if I use that as
cash I would only get its face value
because I have to go to a Chartered bank
or a federally Chartered Bank authorized
by the state of New Hampshire to do
business and it's whatever they will
give me for that coin which is its face
value right now then what do you do with
this 1 o $50 face value gold coin that's
worth spot value
$2,670 at today's spot
price well which which of the which of
the which what what applies that
$1,500 got to run it to the bank or the
spot
price the the face value in this case
would apply okay so you drop it until
like a $50 bill right but in this bill
originally as as the sponsor crafted it
municipalities would have been required
to take silver and gold as legal tender
right and that would include the the
commodity value not the face value of
the coin and that's where the difference
comes in right because a $2 gold coin is
a is just $2 to us I'm guessing it
doesn't happen all that often that
somebody I I would hope that people know
what they have in their hand for value
and would not the coin doesn't make it
all the way to the bank
right so we I I have not heard of that
in my role they stop at a pawn shoping
all right it's possible sure sure all
right so that's a valid concern so and
uh anyhow
so let's uh we'll we'll talk about that
other states have done this and that we
should study what their their approach
was more before um uh offering something
similar to this amendment or something
based off of it as a starting point
something like that yeah well we should
at least offer legislation that I mean
legal tender is legal tender people
should be able to pay with whatever
legal tender they want to pay pay with
and it sounds like we already can and I
think sorry I think I we would want to
find out in addition to whether they've
actually enacted it which you know I
understand substates have whether
whether anybody is actually doing it
whether anybody is walking in to city
tax office with gold coins to pay their
property taxes whether that's actually
happened
yeah probably
rarely um but it is very uh you
mentioned the face value of the coins
and just think about the disconnect
between how what that actual face value
used to be and the value of the metal
that's in the coin it's drastically
there's a big uh it kind of illustrates
how how the dollar is going down in
value each individual unit so anyway we
won't beat that horse to death anymore
so I'll make a motion to uh I'll just
restate what I was going to write in the
committee report subcommittee report not
recommended for future legislation for
House Bill
1674 we need to study other states that
have passed legal tender or species
legal tender as specic bills uh and we
have a list of them and then if we're
going to move forward potentially
looking at
amendment 2 2024
d373 as a starting point uh and and
implementing anything we find in
researching these other states second
all right hopefully I said that
correctly but you did all right all in
favor say I I any opposed all right two
to zero and and we're done thank you
very